the taliban causing sheer terror on the
streets of afghanistan despite promises
of amnesty fox sources telling us the
group is in some areas going door to
door and hanging anyone who worked with
america as new video shows the militants
firing on a group of protesters and
despite awful reports like that the
pentagon spokesperson was unable to say
last night whether or not the taliban is
an enemy
does the u.s military consider the
taliban an enemy
we're our focus right now uh the the
thing we're we're working against right
now is is time and space and we want to
get as many people out of kabul as we
can uh in as little amount of time as we
can there are no hostile interactions
right now between american forces and
the taliban and we want to keep it that
way
that comes as a new report sheds more
light on the american equipment that is
now in the hands of the taliban the
terror group apparently getting
everything from planes and guns to night
vision goggles here's our very own
jennifer griffin on that
we're looking at
images of the taliban they are
holding american m16 rifles that we have
basically resupplied the taliban which
had 70 000
members of a few weeks ago and now
they are they're flooded with 85 billion
dollars of american weaponry and not
just small arms small arms you can get
anywhere but it's the advanced
communications the the
equipment that you can use to move
around the battlefield that's something
russia and china would love to get their
hands on there are advanced weapons you
have
warplanes that were left behind you have
so much we have just flooded this
country with weaponry
yandegan i know you're keeping track
uh of the of the weaponry i i want to
just point out um something in terms of
terror
uh also the terror that we need to worry
about is al-qaeda again having a
sanctuary in afghanistan because of the
taliban that in the press conference
biden was asked
he said al-qaeda is now gone in
afghanistan al-qaeda's gone and then a
short while later jennifer griffin
pressed kirby the defense department
spokesman on that and he reversed course
and admitted that al qaeda has a
presence in afghanistan of course they
do the united nations said that they do
in their recent report actually al qaeda
has presences in 15 provinces
and i called and
this is and jennifer
she was just so incredible today said
this is the same thing it's a repeat of
what began in the early 90s in
afghanistan with a vacuum being created
there i called andy mccarthy who
prosecuted the blind shake and he just
walked me through what was going to
happen he said the terror he said our
defenses here in the united states are
better but fully expect in short order
al qaeda to start hitting our embassies
overseas this is what they did they
declared war on the united states in 96
they hit embassies in africa in 98 they
hit the uss cole in 2000 there were
other plots against our embassies and
that's one of the reasons that our
allies overseas are so upset uncle
merkel called biden out on it and and
blatantly said this is just a political
move
so again terror is coming to the united
states again the only question now is
how soon well and the president said
today that the focus is going to be on
counter-terrorism and using what we can
in that region to you well first of all
we've blown up partnerships so that's
going to be difficult um but there was a
reporter who actually stood up this
afternoon i can't remember which outlet
richard but he asked the president he
said you said that's what that's going
to be our focus but clearly we didn't
monitor this situation accurately so how
do you tell the american people they
should have confidence in what we're
doing well i think that's right shannon
i i'll be honest with you i think that
counterterrorism at this point is a day
late and a dollar short um and the
reason why i say that is because i think
far before we even pulled out of
afghanistan the moment that the taliban
started to re make a resurgence in the
country right which started in 2006 is
when they started to regain territory
from that moment on we should have
expected al qaeda to begin to grow and
the moment that we saw
former presidents start to negotiate
with the taliban was the moment we
should have realized and to be honest
with you i think this is where we as the
american people think greg said this
earlier this week is that
our our leaders in washington what those
that are appointed and elected has been
misleading us for a very long time
because all we've heard is oh we're
doing great in afghanistan oh we need to
surge and when we get this surge it's
all going to work out and we're going to
win but the truth of the matter is since
2006 not because of the failure of our
troops our troops have been doing a
masterful job but because of the failure
to do terrible
go into difficult situations now we put
them in the worst possible absolutely
and because of a failure of washington
leadership both in congress and at the
pentagon at the white house for various
president numerous presidents here we
sit today with the most armed taliban
ever right with the most with the most
sophisticated weapons they were supposed
to go to the afghan military now in
their hands and counter terrorism like i
said at the beginning is a day late and
a dollar short well and now we're in
this situation where we have to get the
people out who are there we've blown up
these partnerships that would have
helped us to get people out of there
i'm talking with some military folks who
have now been able to get civilian and
private charter planes that will come in
and out of there they say they cannot
get the state department to approve
those flights for clearance to assist
our military to get people out they say
that the administration by their account
is in disarray jesse and this extra help
that is standing there is just idle well
people wait i'm not shocked by it we've
heard the report's empty planes flying
off the tarmac we have a deal with the
taliban no offensive weap
no offensive uh
violence against americans in
afghanistan until we withdraw trump
struck that deal biden is a party to
that deal but when he pulled out in such
a sloppy way we lost all leverage so now
the taliban controls everything that
we're doing there and
are we saying the taliban is just
letting everyone through no they're
blackmailing people they're
beating americans up maybe they're not
shooting them dead on the streets but
it's not easy so joe biden is terrified
to say anything until he gets out that's
going to raise hostilities and he's
terrified to do anything because if he
sends
commandos to go extract stranded
americans in kabul or the countryside
and things go sideways and a u.s soldier
dies or god forbid an american citizen
dies joe biden has blood on his hands
and that's going to domino and the whole
country is going to explode so right now
he's tiptoeing around he's at the mercy
of the taliban he's throwing around
money like it's crazy and we have a
deadline coming up and after 9 11 who
knows what happens
also greg are we trying to play nice a
bit with the taliban publicly so that we
can get our people out um i have no idea
i i think that today joe biden said
that terrorism has metastasized around
the world but just months ago not even
just months ago it was the num what was
the number one threat was domestic white
supremacy terror groups so now we know
that he was lying about that especially
today if reuters reports that the fbi
found scant evidence that the riot at
the u.s capitol on january 6th was the
result of an organized plot we all knew
that we saw that with our eyes but but
we had to play along with this stupid
fantasy delusion of white supremacist
phantoms and so what happened was you
had general milly you know wanted to get
at the root of white rage which does not
sound like a general
consumed by winning wars
that that was his priority so what we
were told by our military head and the
president of the united states is that
americans were a bigger threat
than islamic terror they used those
words they said it was bigger than al
qaeda bigger than isis and that was
recently so i see a definite link
between the internal loathing of our
country by our leaders
and this subsequent lack of forethought
in this withdrawal if you are
preoccupied with these phantoms of the
systemic white supremacy of which there
is no proof that has to take up time and
effort replacing intelligent
thought about war and withdrawal i'm not
saying you shouldn't be concerned about
these issues but the military should
have been focused they should have had
their eye on the ball the military heads
not the troops the leaders should have
the right of the wall but they were too
busy playing woke and now well i don't
think so things are mutually exclusive i
think you can be fighting against white
supremacy and also be fighting against
islamic terrorism at the same time
that's like saying cops could be social
workers right but that's what's what's
happening in the state unfortunately hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else